compiling coronavirus lockdown the
streets have never been so empty but
Francis okiya is allowed to deliver
essentials and something else is
different
Francis is one of the few people in
Uganda driving an electric motor bike he
sees a lot of advantages to it
number one it is silent number two
doesn't consume fuel at all
number three wire wire Hills it claims
very well or Kia's food deliveries being
eagle awaited by a pregnant customer
since he saves on fuel he can charge
less than his competitors he's actually
very cheap cheaper than in the other
body guys I think they don't the other
people double the price so literally it
has been convenient for me images from
just weeks ago in Kampala alone they are
about a hundred and thirty thousand
motorcycles aboard the borders the
masses of motorized vehicles generate a
huge amount of air pollution and co2
emissions
that is why the United Nations
Environment Program the unit provides
advice and financial support for
electric mobility in eastern Africa
we need intermediary responses you need
intermediary interventions and electric
mobility is one of those because it is
easier to adopt requires little
infrastructure they meet they don't emit
so you can have a complete reach over
and go on a low-carbon development path
that path requires pioneers like Ben
lock Harry's Korean and here come on
back the graduates of Aachen University
in Germany had a pragmatic idea take the
already existing fuel motorbikes in
Kampala and transform them into electric
bikes so all we remove is what you call
the petrol powertrain petrol driven
power train and we put an electric
powertrain so as you can see it's the
same bike fuel tank is empty of course
and what we put inside is mainly a
controller an electric controller an
electric motor a battery as a source of
power replacing the fuel tank and some
digital controls and a throttle
lithium-ion batteries recovered from old
laptops are assembled into rechargeable
battery units for the ebike and the
recycling loop continues even when the
batteries become too weak to using the
e-bikes so what we do get the newer
batteries use it for immobility after
that when they lose a bit of power we
either put it to put it in storage
systems you know like power banks you
know power reserves and one loses again
you know loses a bit of power we go to
tortures and other smaller applications
before it goes to to be disposed
deliveryman Franciso kia is one of the
20 drivers testing the transformed bikes
on average he has to return to border
walk twice a day to recharge he rents
the batteries for the equivalent of less
than three euros a day all in all these
are Scotty's operating costs by half but
there is still one thing that bothers
him we swap the batteries the feedback
that we are getting from the boarder
guys is also awesome because it it
doubles their income so families school
fees we see kids being brought from the
village that are now schooling in
Kampala because the riders have more
money this rider is German engineer
Daniel dreja he had worked for solar
energy company for several years before
he decided to try to make compilers
motorbikes cleaner with his startup
symbol he now imports cutting-edge
electric motor bikes from China each one
sells for about a thousand euros that's
quite a bit of money but the drivers can
pay over a period of two years and the e
bikes are tailored to their specific
needs here our driving mode is different
than a Chinese person commuting to work
here we really look into productive use
and hundreds of kilometres every day
there is still a long way to go though
all delivery they start up a sold 28
bikes so far and they expect atmo within
the next two months Zambo is already
creating employment Sarah Tabu couldn't
find a job for two years
now she's in charge of marketing
actually it makes me feel very very
proud of myself that I'm contributing a
lot to be part of that the great team
which is actually contributing to two
immobility for a small fee of just over
half a euro assemble driver can exchange
an empty battery twelve fully charged
one his embody bikes are fully green
since the electricity comes from the
solar energy re on top of the company's
building
for most solar charging points a plant
in Kampala soon energy is generated
within the country not like fuel which
is imported from outside so this has a
huge impact on the environment and we
will breathe cleaner air here in Kampala
I see even in ten years no fewer
motorcycles sold anymore in the work
market it's an outdated technology this
green technology behind Francis of Gia's
deliveries is a sign of hope in two ways
providing for people's needs in the
lockdown and for cleaner country once
the pandemic is over
you